aujourd'hui mercredi 19 avril 2023 cela
fait deux jours que la photographe
officielle de l'Élysée sont sur l'accès
aux photos du président à toute notre
rédaction mais vraiment toute notre
rédaction mais tout les journalistes les
documents les monteurs les stagiaires
tout le monde à peine arrivé sur le
parvis de la mairie de Sélestat Emmanuel
Macron n'hésite pas et s'avance vers la
foule sous les hués et les slogans
hostile
il sert quelques mains puis un homme
l'interpelle sans ménagement
[Applaudissements]
pire messieurs dam pire hier on a créé
un compte un peu caché qu'on a appelé
kikou c'est encore nous afin d'avoir
quand même accès à l'information
officielle de l'Elysée poum on s'est
aperçu ce matin qu'elle nous avait aussi
bloqué du coup on fait comment je vais
vous lire ce que vient de déclarer
Emmanuel Macron
Emmanuel Macron plus personne n'a rien à
[__] de ce que dit Emmanuel Macron il
a un rapport au langage complètement
psychotique ce type de croit pas un mot
de ce qu'il prononce il est fou ça
m'intéresse pas
c'est beaucoup trop tard ça fait ça fait
trop longtemps que il pratique une
réplique absolument déconnectée de la
réalité dans quel monde là je suis je
compte pas laisser ma place
déterminé ok je dis ça pour les jeunes
qui ne connaissent pas le langage des
jeunes ok comment on va faire pour
continuer à voir les photos du président
en noir et blanc
et ben on crée un autre compte allez hop
voici notre nouveau compte qui s'appelle
devine c'est qui qui coulent Élysée
devine c'est qui avec un titi qui fait
kikou est-ce que vous savez dans quel
pays on travaille le plus en France en
tout cas alors ça vous êtes un peu
cliché attention et vous allez devoir
écouter Axel de Tarlet à 6h40 j'ai pas
la réponse j'ai pas travaillé ce matin
moi donc je sais pas du tout je crois
que c'est la Suisse aura eu le plus et
mais je crois qu'on est pas si mal
classé que ça bref
on sera avec mode déco quelle est en
pleine forme qui est la travailler donc
ça va nous aider et comme ça on a accès
aux photos du président en noir et blanc
et si il est bloqué demain on en créer
un autre j'en pensais à toc toc toc qui
c'est qui c'est Titou
et après demain aussi et après-demain
aussi pourquoi cette séquence
c'est quoi la séquence
[Rires]
tu peux m'appeler s'il te plaît
je suis pas pour la faire le président
qui a évidemment reçu aussi des preuves
d'amour aujourd'hui le souci c'est que
l'une des seules qui les reçus on a
connu meilleur compliment quoi
et c'est vrai qu'il est belle en vrai
Emmanuel Macron est-ce que vous dites
pas que vous avez poussé le bouchon un
peu trop loin là
quand vous voyez je ferai pas j'ai déjà
eu pire je ferai pas déjà eu c'est exact
mais attendez je suis pas naïf et en
fait vous avez fait une séquence qui
s'intitule alors je le dis qui connaît
le mieux Bernard Montiel
et la première chose qui m'est venue à
l'esprit quand j'ai lu ça je me suis dit
qu'est-ce que les gens ont à [__]
[Applaudissements]
le premier truc qui m'est venu
[Musique]
et oui vous ne rêvez pas Emmanuel Macron
qui chante et qui chante le refuge un
champérinaire pyrénéen pardon qu'il
affectionne c'est que ça lui rappelle sa
grand-mère manette en plein
[Rires]
parisien la façon dont il chantait
certains chants
issus de pays totalitaires le rappeur
Drake
en collaboration avec The Weeknd
grâce à l'intelligence artificielle qui
a réussi à reproduire parfaitement la
voie des deux artistes un Fodio mais une
vraie inquiétude pour leur maison de
disques Universal il voit une nouvelle
menace pour les droits d'auteur
[Musique]
moi m'a fait entendre une chanson
créée par l'IA fait une chanson Philippe
Katerine on m'a envoyé
donc on m'a envoyé cette chanson
franchement je trouvais ça beaucoup
mieux que ce que je fais
j'ai une application pour vous qui
pourrait vous intéresser qui a été créé
par un Belge parce qu'il faut quand même
avoir l'idée ça s'appelle die With Me
alors
mourir avec moi c'est exactement c'est
le nom de cette application et alors
attention il ne s'agit absolument pas de
mourir avec la personne mais de
rencontrer les personnes qui comme vous
au moins de 5 % de batterie au
gouvernement un texto envoyé par Marlène
Schiappa à sa collègue ministre Isabelle
Rome ministre de délégué à l'égalité
homme-femme ils avaient Rome avait
critiqué dans la presse la présence de
Marlène Schiappa dans Playboy voilà ce
qu'a dit Isabelle Rome défendre les
droits des femmes dans Playboy revient à
lutter contre l'antisémitisme en
accordant un entretien arrive à rôle
voilà c'est virulent et de toute
évidence madame Chapa n'a pas digéré la
réponse de Marlène Schiappa et cinglante
d'après le Canard Enchaîné je voulais le
SMS ne pas avoir de notoriété ce n'est
pas grave en politique ne pas avoir
d'action concrète déjà un peu plus ne
pas avoir de tripes encore plus tu n'es
qu'un sac à main de seconde main trouve
le fourrage de me rappeler plutôt que
vous parler dans mon dos
est-ce que ce monde est sérieux
ça va être sympa le prochain conseil des
ministres mais
on est d'accord que c'est un sms entre
Isabelle ROM et Marlène Schiappa donc
c'est soit Isabelle Rome qui le donne au
canard soit Marlène Java donc en fait si
c'est Isabelle Rome c'est pas terrible
mais si c'est Marlène Chavat c'est
encore pire moi je prends le chat
est un homme très pudique et c'est tout
ça qui s'exprime aussi en lui et c'est
ce qui fait aussi sa valeur de d'acteurs
parce que justement il donne pas tout et
c'est très subtil ce qui propose et du
coup c'est magnifique et en tout cas il
nous casse pas les couilles on l'aime